And now...
ASAP Science presents:
The Elements of the Periodic Table
There's Hydrogen and Helium
Then Lithium, Beryllium
Boron, Carbon everywhere
Nitrogen all through the air
With Oxygen so you can breathe
And Fluorine for your pretty teeth
Neon to light up the signs
Sodium for salty times
Magnesium, Aluminium, Silicon
Phosphorus, then Sulfur, Chlorine and Argon
Potassium, and Calcium so you'll grow strong
Scandium, Titanium, Vanadium and
Chromium and Manganese
This is the Periodic Table
Noble gas is stable
Halogens and Alkali react aggressively
Each period will see new outer shells
While electrons are added moving to the right
Iron is the 26th
Then Cobalt, Nickel coins you get
Copper, Zinc and Gallium
Germanium and Arsenic
Selenium and Bromine film
While Krypton helps light up your room
Rubidium and Strontium then Yttrium, Zirconium
Niobium, Molybdenum, Technetium
Ruthenium, Rhodium, Palladium
Silver-ware then Cadmium and Indium
Tin-cans, Antimony then Tellurium and
Iodine and Xenon and then Caesium and...
Barium is 56 and this is where the table splits
Where Lanthanides have just begun
Lanthanum, Cerium and Praseodymium
Neodymium's next too
Promethium, then 62's
Samarium, Europium, Gadolinium and Terbium
Dysprosium, Holmium, Erbium, Thulium
Ytterbium, Lutetium
Hafnium, Tantalum, Tungsten then we're on to
Rhenium, Osmium and Iridium
Platinum, Gold to make you rich till you grow old
Mercury to tell you when it's really cold
Thallium and Lead then Bismuth for your tummy
Polonium, Astatine would not be yummy
Radon, Francium will last a little time
Radium then Actinides at 89
This is the Periodic Table
Noble gas is stable
Halogens and Alkali react aggressively
Each period will see new outer shells
While electrons are added moving to the right
Actinium, Thorium, Protactinium
Uranium, Neptunium, Plutonium
Americium, Curium, Berkelium
Californium, Einsteinium, Fermium
Mendelevium, Nobelium, Lawrencium
Rutherfordium, Dubnium, Seaborgium
Bohrium, Hassium then Meitnerium
Darmstadtium, Roentgenium, Copernicium
Nihonium, Flerovium
Moscovium, Livermorium
Tennessine, Oganesson
And
then
we're
done!!
Thank you guys so much for watching! If you liked the song make sure you check it out on iTunes and Bandcamp, put the link below.
If you think you'd enjoy other videos like this make sure you subscribe to our channel.
And we'll put some of our more recent videos over there, so you go check them out.
You can also check out ASAPscience.com to keep up with everything, what's the latest up with ASAP Science, including stuff like new merch.
Otherwise? We will see you next time! Peace!